how are you doing today sir hey steve i
love that geforce figure right behind
you there
that was like my favorite cartoon as a
kid
hi welcome to the party uh i'm i keep on
hoping that i do all these interviews
with all these big people i keep hoping
that that's going to lead to like a
movie like people saying
you should make that movie they should
totally make that movie 100 it's a great
property
it doesn't anyway i'm willing it into
existence by just constantly having it
here i want to see that too so i read
that you growing up that you idolized
jackie chan and now you're friends with
jackie chan what the hell is that like
that's a it's amazing you know like he i
when i got to hong kong
within probably a month of being in the
industry that i got signed on to his
management company and i was managed by
him for 11 years we did like several
movies together i played the villain to
his hero a couple times and we spent a
lot a lot of time together in fact like
he calls me one of his sons in fact and
oftentimes when he is yet his his son is
younger than me he'll often call me to
tell me to tell his son to stop doing
something because he knows how to listen
to me and not him right and so we've
developed this very very close
relationship over time and it's just
like
it's amazing to have idolized him from
my youth to being able to become like
you know part of the family is an
amazing experience and also just to be
able to learn from him and his freaking
work ethic is like no no i've never seen
anybody like that it's the fact that
he's working all the time and he just
can't stop it's kind of amazing
i am very curious as a fan of his uh do
you have a favorite film and a favorite
stunt because he has done some
incredible [ __ ] oh god um drunken master
ii is probably my favorite film in terms
of pure kung fu style but i think the
i think it's eastern condors is that the
name you know where the he does the fall
off the one where he smashed his head
open that one where
he felt the several awnings like some of
those things are just so crazy like
obviously nowadays nobody does stuff
like that but
the incredible feats that he was able to
do back in the days and just like put
his life on the line and i've also
witnessed like the results of that this
pain like he's in a lot of pain um now
because of all the stuff that he's done
in the past you know constant pain and
and so uh it's a good it was a good
reminder to me to like take care of my
body
and not throw myself off top of the
building you know when you get the
chance
yeah i i do believe that he no matter
how much praise you give jackie chan it
is not enough um
jumping i i gotta ask you before avi i'm
going to run out of time um but for
specifically for the reason i get to
talk to you what was it about this
script and story that said i want to do
this
well i think several factors one is the
cast but also lisa joy in her writing
and the way she wrote the st joe
character she wanted this villain to be
you know evil and dark and scary but
also vulnerable and and almost seductive
and attracted to the audience as well
like oh that's an interesting challenge
right you don't want you know
oftentimes villains are relegated to a
kind of two-dimensional bad guy or
caricature right and so she didn't want
that she wanted this guy to be very
three-dimensional and almost mere or
hugh's character and so like you see a
lot of similarities they fell in love
with the same woman they were hurt by
the same woman they're both heartbroken
by the same woman and then also they're
selling similar things he's selling this
machine this opportunity to get this
machine to escape the president and live
in the past and i'm selling this drug
that allows people to escape the the
nasty present that they're living in now
and so to see these kind of the way she
set up these characters and how they're
kind of the answers
of each other but also very similar was
kind of an interesting challenge for me
thank you so much for giving me your
time have a great day thank you so much